[Music]
this episode is brought to you by me
undies me undies makes the softest
undies known to man that's what the copy
says and they are soft they're really
soft whether you like crazy prints or
opt for classic black me undies gives
you the freedom to express yourself
comfortably I wonder what expressing
yourself of course within legal bounds
means in this case but I do like to
express myself I'm wearing some tie-dye
me undies right now as I record this in
the room next to me I've got some pizza
and videogame prints those are not on
the same pair of underwear but two
separate ones
but I'll be packing for a trip and I
have a nice stack of me Andy's going
with me why because they're comfortable
very very comfortable mewn DS has plenty
of options for those looking to up their
undie game you can join the monthly
membership you can do build a pack that
is building a three six or ten pack of
your favourite undies or socks and
saving up to 30% you can select a
matching pair to match with your better
half or just pick out one pair that
strikes your fancy and there are some
pretty ridiculous ones that I specialize
in personally my undies are made with
soft sustainable fabric and available in
sizes from extra small to four XL fun
new prints drop every tuesday and
members get access to exclusive prints
every month munities has a great offer
for listeners of this podcast for any
first-time purchase you get 15% off and
free shipping they also give you a 100%
satisfaction guarantee and I like to be
satisfied with my underwear to get your
15% off your first order free shipping
and a 100% satisfaction guarantee go to
me on DS dot-com / Tim that's me undies
comm / Tim
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs hiring can be hard really
hard and it can also be super super
expensive and painful if you get it
wrong I certainly have had that
experience firsthand multiple times and
I am NOT eager to repeat it so I tried
to do as much vetting as possible on the
front end and today with more qualified
candidates than ever you need a solution
you need a platform that helps you to
find the right people for your business
LinkedIn jobs does exactly that more
than 600 million users visit LinkedIn to
learn make connections grows
professionals and more than ever
discover new job opportunities in fact
overall LinkedIn members add 15 new
skills to their profiles and apply to
thirty five job posts every two seconds
that's a crazy stat LinkedIn does the
legwork to match you to your most
qualified candidates so that you can
focus on the hiring process getting the
person into your company who will
transform your business they make sure
your job post gets in front of the
people with the right heart skills and
soft skills to meet your requirements
they've made it as easy as possible so
check it out to get $50 off of your
first job post go to linkedin.com slash
to him again that's linkedin.com slash
Tim to get $50 off of your first job
post terms and conditions apply check it
out
linkedin.com slash Tim
well hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where does my
job each in every episode
to interview world-class performers or
people who are exceptionally good at
what they do domain experts who can
speak to the subtleties of a given
subject industry or skill and my guest
today covers a lot of bases his name is
Tristan Harris at Tristan Harris TR is
TN h AR AR is on twitter Rolling Stone
has named him one of the 25 people
shaping the world
Tristana was featured in fortunes 2018
40 under 40 list for his work on
reforming technology and the Atlantic
has called him the closest thing Silicon
Valley has to a conscience formerly
design ethicist at Google he is a
world-renowned expert on how technology
steers our decisions justdon't has spent
nearly his entire life studying subtle
psychological forces from early
beginnings as a childhood magician we
talked quite a bit about this and also
his study of pickpocketing and other
fascinating domains that I'm very very
interested in to working with the
Stanford persuasive technology lab and
to his role as CEO of aperture which was
acquired by Google Tristan has briefed
heads of state technology company CEOs
and members of US Congress about the
attention economy and he's been featured
in media worldwide including 60 Minutes
PBS Newshour and many more he is the
co-founder of the Center for Humane
technology which can be found at humane
tech dot-com please enjoy without
further ado my wide-ranging conversation
with Tristan Paris
Tristan welcome to the show thanks for
having me Tim I am thrilled to finally
have you on the line to have a
wide-ranging conversation because we
have many mutual friends and many of my
listeners have requested you on the show
and I thought that perhaps a a good
place to start would be beautiful Bali
Bali Indonesia
I have in my notes here a bullet that
references a retreat in Bali that's an
Indonesia for folks who are curious
about Bali on hypnosis pickpocketing and
magic so let's let's dig into that why
good why go to such a thing and what did
you learn did you accidentally sign any
powers of attorney or walk out the empty
pocket it was actually one of the best
life choices that I think I've ever made
you know I was as a magician that is
there as a kid I was a magician early on
and got interested and really just
siphoned up all of his information from
books and things like that but then I it
wasn't really a thing that was going
active in my life as an adult but then
about I don't know sometime in 2016 I
saw this I was part of this newsletter
by I think his name is James Brown he's
a hypnotist based in the UK and he said
he was gonna run a workshop on hypnosis
pickpocketing and magic in Bali and I
just thought this is too good to pass up
it was about the one week of vacation I
had in the year and ended up going out
there and it was something like me and
eight or nine magicians I was probably
the most amateur and it was so much fun
because every night you just have these
magicians going out on the town like we
go to a bar somewhere in Bali and they
would just clean up not clean up in a
sense of their money in their wallets
but in the sense of just having fun with
people and you would just watch these
guys you know play with people's
attention in ways that you know they
didn't know what they were up against
and it wasn't pickpocketing in an
adversarial sense like let me get all
your money it was done in putting money
into pockets yeah
yeah it was done in the in the guise of
hey I'm a magician this is what I do but
you know you want to have some fun and
but it's just really fascinating
especially pickpocketing I don't know if
you know Apollo Robbins I don't but I'm
definitely going to look this person
hope to learn more he's also one of the
sort of world's most famous pickpockets
he's a he's a teddy actually helped me
with my TED talk when I was there and
you know he's just has he actually
worked in collaborated with a bunch of
neuroscientists on essentially the
limits of attention and stuff that he
had picked up just by doing it but then
is later now being confirmed by it by
neuroscience and that's what I find
fascinating about magic and
pickpocketing is they were kind of the
first applied psychologists I'm they've
been doing this for hundreds of years
right and I just love that you know our
science is catching up to what the
practitioners have known how to do for
for a long time and I'd love for you to
perhaps talk to some of the techniques
or principles behind good magic or
pickpocketing and I'm sure there are and
we'll have a chance to explore parallels
in other places but for instance
speaking from my own personal experience
I about a month ago had a chance to go
to the Magic Castle in Los Angeles for
the first time and the recommendation
from the member who brought us in was to
go to the close-up room the close-up
magic room and its seats somewhere
between 12 and 20 people it's very small
room and there's a table right in front
of you it was about five feet from me
and after the performance that we saw
which was which was truly staggering I
mean it was just world-class in terms of
sleight of hand number of friends are
with me one of very high-end musician
the other very successful entrepreneur
and then a number of other folks walked
out and said I have to question
everything in my reality because of what
could be done right in front of you I
mean literally right in front of you
right are there any particular sort of
technique
or principles that stand out for you in
the realm of magic pit pocketing
hypnosis or other in terms of these
practitioner arts I mean the the
punchline is it's really about the
limits of attention and in all of the
cases right I mean I think you're also
getting at is you've had some pretty
successful people by your side it sounds
like I mean business people
entrepreneurs the thing about magic that
I always found most interesting is that
it has nothing to do with the level like
you your level of being inoculated from
the effect has nothing to do with your
intelligence right right it's like which
is so fascinating right because you you
could have the most successful business
person or you know off-the-charts
prodigy in mathematics or something like
that but it has nothing to do with the
extent to which they can be fooled in a
close up you know experience or
pickpocketing and that they are living
in separate different domains that those
are two different areas of skill or
inoculation I found fascinating because
I think it says so much about what magic
is doing it's not about intelligence
it's about something more subtle and
about the weaknesses or the limits of
the blind spots of the biases that we're
all trapped inside of you know I always
say it's like we're trapped in a
mind-body meatsuit that has a set of you
know bindings and and bendings to to how
we see the world that you don't know
that you're living inside of that
corrective tissue that happens to Bend
attention in that way I mean so
misdirection is the core principle you
know you look over here and you think
you're looking you know you think you're
gonna catch the magician doing it
because you're looking where you would
think that he doesn't want you to look
but he's probably by that point already
you know four steps ahead of you
so right it's like by the time you're
looking at the place or the other hand
its must be any other hint but like that
you're behind it happened three steps
ago and usually there's a setup so
sometimes the the actual trick has
happened you know at the very beginning
and then there's there's layers upon
layers that are being built and the
magician is usually working two or three
steps ahead I wish I could get more you
know can create examples by you know the
magician's code is you don't you don't
give this stuff up to public the funny
thing about magic of course is it's all
actually is all public you just have to
buy book but times that people don't
read books and so it remains a secret
um but you know I think that in
pickpocketing what was fascinating is
it's you know people think oh do you
grab it when I'm not looking and it's
not like that at all I mean as a
pickpocket the person will stand right
up next to you they'll look at you
they'll talk to you you're just having a
conversation they will with you they
will look down at your left pocket and
they'll tap it and they'll say oh so
what's what's in that pocket over there
and then you'll pull out you know keys
and a wallet and you look at it say okay
that's interesting what's in that wall
and they'll you know you're right there
with them as they're doing this and then
it's in this other room when they say
they'll look at what's happening in the
other pocket and they'll turn around and
walk around you and there's all this
mischief that starts to happen in those
moments in between but what's
interesting about pickpocketing is the
way people on the outside the public
tends to think about it is they just
kind of grab it when you're not looking
but what's fascinating is it actually
happens right underneath your nose so I
just I love it it's it's so amazing to
watch these guys work there you were
very recently is testifying the right
verb here or presented what is yeah
maybe the the lead witness in a Senate
hearing on persuasive technology and if
I'm remembering correctly and feel free
to to fact-check this but you talked
about the magician's choose a pick pick
a card any card or alluded to that might
have been in your TED talk it was in it
was in one of the two but in what will
come back to the to Washington DC but
the when you mention that it it's to try
to try to tie two things together here
it made me think of the you know if you
control the menu you control the choices
which is one of the hijacks you talk
about can you can you describe this can
you elaborate on that yeah well I mean
we tend to live in you know we're in
United States and we tend to live in a
libertarian culture that's all about
celebrating and protecting the freedom
to make our own choices but at a very
very very deep level we don't we're not
also taught to question who controlled
the menu of choices that we are picking
from this
also occurs I think at a deep like
spiritual or identity level you know you
can make any choice you want but you
don't see the invisible constraints on
how you are seeing the world in such a
way that you know you're only picking
from the five habitual things that your
mind that shows up in your mind on a
daily basis but in magic I mean the
principle is just and it's actually more
nuanced in this I means funny Darren
brown the famous Mentalist I was
emailing with him the other day and he
was saying I could probably teach you
some some things to update your
interview that this is the most
important principle in magic but you
know if you control the the menu and the
order of options as they're presented
and the emphasis as they're presented
you you can I mean I wish I could do a
demo here but I'm not a good enough
fishin to do it live you know you can
make it seem as if someone has whittled
down from the entire deck of cards down
to one from 52 cards down to one and it
seems as if they've made their own free
choice along the way in like four
distinct choice you know moments but in
fact you know exactly what card you
wanted them to get to all along and you
know the kind of questions you can ask
people shape the outcome the kinds of
sequencing of the questions the meaning
making it it's hard to do this without
actually giving people the the you know
the whole techniques but I think this is
something that is really important to
understand whether it's in the way that
technology presents menus to us or the
way that society or culture do you know
any any way you choose you're still
choosing within a menu that has other
people's interests behind it yeah you
mentioned invisible constraints so these
the the assumptions that we may not be
aware that we're making or the box that
we've created for ourselves in some
fashion or adopted from our environment
or our parents or other places are there
any any particular sort of tools or
mental models or anything at all that
you use to try to identify the invisible
constraints in your life yeah I mean
it's a great question I mean
fundamentally I feel like the process of
waking up or awakening is is to try to
see assumptions that were made
or you know guiding principles and our
choices that in our even asking the
right questions like so let's say right
after this interview you know you get
outside and you could go in any
direction like what is that just think
about that that moment so I'll leave
this this podcast studio and you'll
leave your your house and then what
comes up into your mind about where to
go right I mean it's a usually a set of
habits maybe it's like Oh what do I need
to do let me refer to my to-do list what
is it you know which cafe do I want to
go to for an iced coffee to run away
from that anxiety that I was feeling
because I don't know what to do with
myself there's this limited we're kind
of creatures of habits right and so
especially when we're inside of embedded
environments that we've been in for long
periods of time we tend to play out the
same patterns over and over again this
is where the you know this is both a
kind of a new-age throwaway statement
and also a real one which is you know
wherever you are or does like that was
they call again I think it's wherever
you go there you are
yes something like that the just in book
title so friend and you know it's the
point is that you we repeat our same
mental habits
everywhere we go so you know in in so
many ways that are often invisible to us
we don't notice the consistency of a
kind of a structure to the way our minds
happen to process information or the way
that we think about what to do with our
time or the way that we value things or
we sort things all those processes that
are sitting inside of us you know
happening all the time are often
invisible and not available for
introspection and they basically run our
whole life which is why they say like oh
maybe I'll go on a meditation retreat or
maybe I'll go find myself in Bali but
then you know you find that you know and
as I know from your meditation
experience with you know the monkey mind
it's like we just have these recurring
processes that follow us everywhere and
I think if you can't see them then they
run your life and then we're kind of
like otama tons where robots that are
living according to the previous set of
constraints and the extent to which we
have choices the extent to which we see
those patterns as far as techniques to
to see them I mean I think that's tricky
I don't have you ever done the work of
Byron Katie I have I
I find the number of her one-sheets
sort of these one-page worksheet prompts
to be very helpful it takes a little
getting used to it can seem very strange
and nonsensical at first but I think if
you're willing to force yourself to do
the thought exercise of contorting the
the beliefs you know these statements
that you take is true it's it's super
valuable could you could you describe if
you've done it how you've done it it
sounds super abstract for those people
haven't seen a baby I mean she's
basically just come up with a set of
four questions you can ask of any moment
in your life that causes stress because
usually what's happening is you're you
are creating that stress for your own
mind and you just can't see it yet so I
I kind of think about it too letting it
to the magic metaphor that our brains
are living inside of this 24/7 magic
trick which is that whatever thought
pops into our mind we believe it we
don't not believe it we just we
automatically step into it and we see
the world through that thought through
the assumptions of that thought and
essentially what what her four questions
do is they let you see the exact
opposite of that belief which then
question likes you not take your beliefs
and your thoughts so seriously and it's
a great parity with with meditation but
essentially it's something like um I
don't know for example you're driving
and there you are and then some guy in a
red Corvette like cuts you off and
you're like I don't know something like
that guy is an [ __ ]
or something like that right and you
were convinced at it every bone in your
body every bit of your nervous system
just you know for sure this guy is
impatient he's you know inconsiderate
all of these thoughts just rush into
your mind and you have utter certainty
about your experience and who this other
person is right um let alone the fact
you don't know if this person is rushing
to go get their wife who's at the
hospital because something's wrong I
mean you don't know right so that four
questions are okay that person you know
that guy is inconsiderate the first
question is
is that true that guy is inconsiderate
and you have to like pause and sit there
you know there you are in the car
looking at this person and say that
guy's in case it's not true okay the
second question is usually to reinforce
that and loosen up
maybe the beliefs a bit which is can you
be absolutely sure that it's true that
that guy is inconsiderate and you
realize no I can't in fact I just
thought that the moment that he you know
step you know ran in front of me okay so
then we'll get to the third question
which is okay what happens what do i
what how do I react what images come to
mind how do I feel how do I relate to
the world how do I relate to him when I
believe the thought that guys and
consider it you know what happens and
the answer would be something like I see
him as you know naive I see him as
thoughtless I see much you know I don't
care about him I I want him to be you
know moved off the face of the earth i I
want that car out of my way I get angry
my my body I feel you know all these
things but the entire your trying to
basically list the ecology of just with
that one belief in that one moment if
that guy isn't considerate does to your
whole nervous system so it's like a full
body scan kind of full belief scan of
what that does and you sort of see oh my
god just by believing that one thought
it's totally transformed my entire
experience in that moment with reality I
am now seeing reality in a totally
different way and usually in a more
distorted disconnected not centered not
calm not not connected way and then the
fourth question is once you realize the
kind of absurdity of that ecology of
beliefs is who would I be in that moment
without the thought that that guy is
inconsiderate and so there he is he
crosses you know he cuts over right in
front of me but without the thought that
guy is inconsiderate maybe it's
something like I have curiosity about
what happened why did he do that you
know whatever you let you get that
ecology and then the last step is to
list the opposites of the belief so
instead of that guy is inconsiderate one
opposite is that guy is very considerate
or he is considerate
and you try to find evidence is there
any way in which that could be true and
you know in that moment prior to doing
this process you were convinced that
this guy just was absolutely
inconsiderate but as you after you've
done those four questions you think is
there any evidence for him being
considerate well what if he's on the way
to the hospital to meet you know his
wife who just who just you know got his
in labor or something from being
pregnant and you realized that he could
be the most considerate person you know
in that way or another
opposite to he's inconsiderate could be
I am inconsiderate and the evidence
there would be that I'm inconsiderate of
the fact that I don't know the ecology
of this other person's life and I
rapidly jumped to conclusions so what
this process does and I mean I feel like
they need to go through it for so long
but it it shows you something
fundamental about the ways that our mind
trap us in you know almost like a
permanent fixed set of glasses that
temporarily occupy the way that we see
the world and make meaning and when we
see that you just stop taking of your
thoughts and your beliefs quite so
seriously and you realize that even in
those moments when you're stressed and
you're convinced it's because the world
really is you know doing that thing that
pisses you off it lets you see maybe I'm
actually doing this for myself and that
also games it increases responsibility
because that means that now we're
responsible for our own experience as
opposed to you know the world is
constantly terrorizing us with
situations thank you very much for that
overview there we go on so long that was
though that was really good
that was really good I spent two days
with Byron Katie in a small group and
for people who are listening I I will
confess something that someone listening
might also experience which is when I
was first given this exercise and did it
as related to a few different situations
I had a lot of resistance just the yet
stuck it struck me as this sort of
semantic tail-chasing or the highly
abstract and when you dig into it if you
give it a chance as a thought exercise
it's it's
it can be incredibly valuable I mean
some of the transformations that I
witnessed in the room with people who
had long-standing beliefs about say a
family member which were which were
completely crippling like had paralyzed
a family situation I was was really
remarkable and you mentioned the the
three questions here is it true can you
absolutely know it's true how do you
react what happens when you believe that
thought and who would you be without
that thought a couple of a couple of
points that were really valuable to me
or questions to ask so sort of as a
subsection under how do you react what
happens when you believe that thought
one of the subsets of that that Byron
Byron Katie has on the websites just the
work calm and you can file this stuff
for free is you know do any obsessions
or addictions begin to appear when you
believe that thought I think this is
yeah it's a really really good one and
really important you mentioned leading
into this you know do you go to the
coffee shop to drink a coffee because
you're overwhelmed or worried about not
knowing what to do right and right then
that likely triggers a whole new set of
physical sensations which trigger a
whole set of sort of emotional and
thought responses which you might blame
on the circumstances of two hours before
but in fact you just took down 200
milligrams of caffeine and four minutes
right so yeah like fractal levels of
running away from anxiety you know
running away from anxiety creates an
experience that that's an addiction that
then creates more anxiety that we then
run away from and we spend our whole day
clicking between Facebook and email
Facebook and email and then you're like
what am i Diego exactly and the the the
last thing for now that I'd like to say
about this because I'm really glad you
brought up is that the the portion of
creating the opposites is where I had
the most resistance and the for instance
that person is very considerate or I am
inconsiderate and so on and there are a
whole bunch of different ways that you
can you can turn these sentences around
the only way I could really get through
the exercise was to say if I had a gun
against my head and had to come up with
three hypothetical cases where this
could be true whatever the the
permutation is what would they be and
it's really powerful and and I don't
want to be labor the point but I do
encourage everybody to check it out and
try it out I'm really glad you brought
it up yeah I mean it's I totally
appreciate what you're saying not to
dwell so much on on her work you know it
actually has been impactful for I think
probably other things we may talk about
is you just you just realized the way
that the mind so quickly steps into some
new belief with with utter certainty you
know and just to your point like you
know when you find these opposites like
well maybe I'm not considerate maybe
that person is so considerate it's like
now sometimes that guy just is
inconsiderate like he actually just
wasn't looking and he's not trying to
rush to save his wife and you know
whatever else right I mean there's
definitely an argument you could make
that he was being inconsiderate and it's
not meant to deny facts about reality
about someone else's you know objective
state but I think what it does overall
is makes you realize that we live in
utter certainty about a world that's
highly uncertain and that whenever
stress comes about through that process
we might be able to you know down
regulate a lot of that stress by just
not taking our thoughts and beliefs
quite so seriously I mean it's an
amazing tool and I you know that well
that's a technology anyway because I
think technology is this sort of false
belief factory like it just generates
you know all of these false beliefs
there's moment by moment by moment by
moment and I mean the premise of her
work and doing this process is so that
you don't identify with your thoughts I
mean the fourth question she asks which
is who would you be without the thought
it's not what would happen instead if
you didn't think he's inconsiderate
it's who would you be so it's an
identity level question and this
actually is really important because
when you're doing belief transformation
work when you do identity level work
it's much more persuasive than if you if
we want to link this to the stuff I know
about
Russia's influence campaign in the 2016
elections I mean a lot of it was
identity level work like we are African
Americans and Hillary doesn't care about
us that was the message that from Russia
went after it's because identity level
propaganda and you know identity
politics it's it's the deepest level of
psychological influence work now in the
Byron Katie sense she's doing it to try
to empower people to overcome the ways
that they their brain lies to them and
deceives them and the other sense it can
be used obviously to manipulate people
but you know in studying I don't know
have you've done more linguistic
programming you know I first read I have
not done any training at least not
directly but beginning in high school
which is I think when Tony Robbins
really put an LP on the main stage in
some respects became fascinated by the
prospect or the implications as
described by Tony Robinson his first
book of NLP but could you describe that
for people who don't know what it is
yeah I mean I'm not an expert but I have
taken some some workshops in it I mean
mystic programming is essentially a
study of how language and thought and
meaning are you know basically each of
us have a map in our own brain of how we
see reality we're not actually directly
in touch with the reality and formulas
we're living through this mediated map
that you know and based on good choices
we use it shapes the reality that we
that we have it's used in hypnosis it's
actually the basis for ericksonian
hypnosis and you know how you what kind
of language choices to make and how you
can deepen people's experience or
alleviate people's experience like a
simple example just to make it concrete
is something like you know think of a
person that you love and see their see
their face in your in your mind's eye
and then turn up the colors so like just
make the colors more vivid do you feel
more of the love or do you feel less of
the love when you turn up the colors how
about if you bring the image even closer
so bring it up way close right in front
of you and turn up the colors you know
and then just playing it just noticing
that even as you you do this you get
different kinds of feelings and
experiences versus for example if you
turn down the colors you make it
grayscale what if you make it small move
it very far away
these are all ways of playing with you
know human cognition and experience and
you know anyway when you do this kind of
work there's it's used in counseling
psychological counseling as well and
when you when you work with people on an
on a counseling level if you can do
identity level transformation work where
for example if you ask someone the
phrase are you an athlete you know I
mean if I ask you all right would you
say you're an athlete when I'm not
eating donuts and sitting all day I
would like to think of myself as an
athlete I used to be an athlete would be
my real answer I'd say I used to be an
athlete so this is that like you sort of
quill your nervous system if you say the
phrase like I am and I used to be an
athlete does that feel like the most
accurate thing for you it does yeah but
I think athlete competitive athlete so
that's I would say I used to be an icing
right so there you go so that's your map
right it's like athlete for you means
competitive athletes in some kind of
professional sense well just interesting
I mean a lot of people would probably
answer that question no right and yet a
lot of people I mean I might answer that
question no but you know do you exercise
you know do you do you go to the gym do
you you know I do boxing and some
kickboxing stuff for fun just fitness
classes and you know I wouldn't put
myself in the category of athlete but
just notice that that's just you know
whether I fall on the sign of side of
yes or no to that question has a really
big implication for how I see myself
right definitely and and it's totally
arbitrary whether or not I call myself
as part of the category of I am an
athlete versus I'm not and what would
make me an athlete like what a criteria
well there we go now I'm inspecting the
map inside my brain that I've invisibly
constructed some set of rules about when
you've officially qualify for being an
athlete and when you don't and it's all
artificial it's all arbitrary it's just
coming from our own mind happening to
organize these rules and and obligations
which are self constructed and it's
through the NLP type stuff or Byron
Katie stuff that you can actually play
with all this and you realize that
you're living in this fractal kind of
Hall of Mirrors in your mind that you
know makes us think or believe all these
things that are just kind of distortions
self constructed out of invisible parts
of our brain and waking up is the
process by which we can you know shatter
some of the glasses and and see
clearly yeah and waking up mean that if
feel free to to to offer a counterpoint
it seems to me that waking up here is at
least in part simply becoming aware of
your habitual processes right and yeah
it's kind of like he's stepping out of
the movie itself in which you're the
lead actor or actress and stepping back
into the audience and watching becoming
the observer of your own behavior and
you know what you were saying earlier
about thoughts and beliefs in how how
much conviction we can have a snap
judgment Odle reminds me of something
that BJ Miller is a doctor and hospice
care physician who's been on the podcast
who's helped something like a thousand
people to die his answer to the question
I often ask which is what would you put
on a billboard is he actually got from a
bumper sticker so I don't know the
original attribution but it's don't
believe everything that you think right
which is a lot and the I think about
language a lot because I mean we're
talking about language I mean to some
extent we're talking about labels and if
we're talking about labels were talking
about conceptual overlays that we're
putting on top of our sensory input
right so it's really like how you're
constructing reality and when you look
at something I we don't have to go into
in depth right now but if people search
for the the 21-day no complaint
experiment there's a want to say pasture
might be a reverend will bow and might
be Bowen Bo w en who began doing an
experiment with his congregation in
which they would wear a rubber band or a
wristband that was elastic and they
would they attempted to go 21 days
without complaining and there are
parameters which were mostly language
based for what constituted a complaint
and if you complained you had to switch
your wrists and start your 21-day clock
over again and the the the effects on
people who completed the 21 days or even
made it halfway on quality of
if on their thinking and the lens
through which they've looked at reality
was so profound and if you really look
at the nitty-gritty of it it's it's
training and awareness of the the
statements in your mind and the
statements that you use just like Byron
Katie's the work in a set exactly I mean
in essence I mean it's like this is why
not to switch in the technology stuff at
least not yet but you know what you say
the attention economy is beneath all
other economies like the psychology like
that if you had a you know an amplifier
or a voice out like an output for all of
the thoughts running through our heads I
mean this this is what constitutes our
inner lives this is the this is the
soundtrack this is the things that were
repeating invisibly we don't even notice
that we're repeating it because it's
almost doesn't have audio but
immediately I mean I've done I know you
have done lots of meditation and on a
seven day meditation retreat I once did
that's what I was most surprised by was
just how quickly these next thoughts
would come up and that how quickly I was
tempted to believe them and what you
know the whole like you know wherever
you go there you are like the same
patterns of thoughts would come up like
the same self-doubt or the same
self-criticism
you know I don't want this to sound dull
for listeners because I know that when
people describe these things from a
distance that doesn't sound as
interesting as profound but your point
about language you're just making me
think I remember where I first
encountered your work Tim which was um
at least it was one of the early
recommendations you made I think in
4-hour workweek about the 22 immutable
laws of marketing yes and which is also
was a profound book for me and you know
the example of marketing is all about
using language to manipulate perception
and the fact that your mind organizes
information in particular ways I
remember one core thing in that book is
just the way that our minds create kind
of ladders of you know in competition
like invisible categories like safety
you know which is the number one safest
car in the world for you know what's the
most safe car in the world and everyone
says Volvo great what's the second
safest car in the world and you realize
your mind draws a blank it's because
your mind doesn't even organize
information pass slot number one
um and it's all based on the slots you
know what's the fastest car in the world
was the safest car in the world and you
know I think it's the same thing in our
own lives that invisibly the way we
construct you know am I an athlete or
not I mean these are the it's just this
again the set of structure of identity a
belief meaning that makes up and
constitutes you know our well-being what
choices we make whether we dare to take
those risks with a we dare to jump off a
cliff whether we look at the world's
problems in the face
I think the psychology is everything and
it doesn't seem important if you haven't
looked inside which yeah is also
fascinating that people can spend their
whole lives not even you know looking
looking in and hearing what the words
that keep showing up in our brains are I
didn't do my first meditation retreat I
think until I was 32 well you beat me I
would did mine just a few years ago so I
was probably 39 or 40 and for those
people who want a little comedic relief
one of the terms that one of the
coordinators used I don't know if it was
jack Kornfield himself he was there at
spirit rock and it may have been one of
the other teachers but they joked about
Vipassana vendetta's where people in the
room would become so preoccupied with
like the person 10 feet away who's
coughing too often or if it was like
shuffling too often harassed like the
noisy jacket with the zipper yeah and it
becomes this sort of obsessive focus
which happens all the time in daily life
it's just not as obvious if totally -
it's funny you mentioned this because
you know when you're an admission treat
you're in silence for days and what I
find fascinating is the way that for
whatever reason you just kind of your
mind locks onto people and you start
making judgments about like oh yeah you
think like that person over there oh
they just think this or like look at the
way to fate you know sort of themselves
food quietly like they're just a slob or
you know whatever the thing that comes
out it and and then what's funny is like
I don't know a few experience that's put
in the last day of my meditation retreat
obviously we had this little we start
finally talk to each other and you get
to know who people are and you realize
just how off-base you were you know and
and he's invisible you know the how
quickly our mind jumps to conclusions
about people for whom we've literally we
have never talked to it we've never
inspected the contents of their mind
we're just we can obsessed with it and
reminds me of another attention exercise
I did it at Burning Man once that was
really powerful actually like if you're
ever in a group setting this is a super
meta mind kind of podcast interview so
hopefully we don't find this too
conceptual and abstract but it's
actually really fun stuff I mean our
attention is so profoundly happening
without us really realizing it but this
this exercise I did you're a room with
people it's like 30 people and you're
walking around in silence and then you
kind of stay on the edge and you're led
by a facilitator to first look around
the room so there you are looking at all
the 30 people and you're looking on the
room and it says I'll say it like so
first just look around the room and
notice who you have noticed like notice
that there's certain people certain
faces that you've drawn that draw a lot
more of your attention than other people
like right like 30 people you would
think like oh yeah we just read pay
attention all 30 but actually if you
look closely your mind is actually
paying attention to a subset for
whatever reason there's a subset of
people who you find more interesting
second question was our second prompt
let's look around the room and now
notice the people that for whatever
reason you don't like like you don't
even know why you don't like them you
just or you're just not interested to
connect with them or you you would not
want to be with them or talk to them
just notice that there's some people
you've already selected that you didn't
want to talk to and isn't that
interesting like what about them has you
feeling like I don't even want to talk
to them and then the third prompt was
look around the room and notice all the
people you didn't even notice
they're like the people in between the
faces who even belong completely skips
over and you don't even notice that
you're doing that and it's a really
profound exercise there's a lot there's
some other steps to it but it really
shows you that you know your mind is
living inside of the selection filter
that is pre selecting certain bits of
information to reach your conscious
awareness and then hiding lots of others
and also polarizing you against
you know people or sources of
information and you don't even know why
you're just living inside of that hammer
that's wanting to treat everything like
a nail but you don't even know the
direction of the hammer and that there
are lots of nails yeah definitely and I
was also as you're as you're talking
about this these selection filters right
and those 22 immutable laws of marketing
for people who want to look at the power
of words through a different lens and
this this came up for me actually I
should say this person Frank Luntz came
up for me I know yeah yeah so he's come
up for me and a few different scenarios
one a friend of mine very very very
actually a mutual friend of ours but I
won't name by name certainly very
socially liberal guy recommended I think
it's words that work I think those words
words that work yeah yeah it's not what
they what you said it's what people hear
is by Frank Luntz and this then he came
up recently because I was watching Vice
the movie about Dick Cheney and there's
a Frank Luntz for those people they
don't know yeah and I'm reading directly
from Wikipedia here is he's an American
political consultant pollster and public
opinion guru best known for developing
talking points and other messaging for
various Republican causes but and I'll
skip a bunch of it just to give a few
examples he advocated use of vocabulary
crafted to produce a desired effect
including use of the term death tax
instead of estate tax and climate change
instead of global warming those are
really powerful vocabulary reframes
really really powerful if you think of
the implication the implications of
those reframes totally and this this is
a B where were we can certainly chat
about about Frank and the power of words
but the the sort of meta so feel free to
jump in with anything you'd like to say
but yeah I mean I it's it's I love you
bringing this up I mean I hope this
again isn't met a you know trippy for
for people listening there's so much
focus on language but it does shape
everything I mean again
people think climate change versus
global warming the whole point is well
climb it's always changing right there's
nothing to worry about cause it's always
changing it's a neutral statement it
another one that's like Frank is uh you
know he's often not to be on the right
and there's this guy George Lake Hoff
who's on the left who wrote a book
called metaphors we live by and he's
like academic linguist um who you know
is talked about the power of grounding
metaphors so grounding metaphor is if
you think about something like the
nation as a family so invisibly when we
think about the nation it's structured
at least in English as part of the
family so we don't send our sons and
daughters to war we don't want those
missiles in our backyard right you know
if there's a third ones here I forgot
shoot our founding fathers
yeah our founding fathers you know it
said that is it there are fathers really
yeah they are they really are fathers so
invisibly you know we have this baked
into our language at a structural level
that that organizes almost like a
geometry of meaning about how we see the
nation those are our sons and daughters
those are our founding fathers those
this is our backyard being our property
you know and it conjures up a whole
bunch of assumptions about how we see
the world that then structure you know
entire political beliefs about whether
to go to war and all this kind of stuff
and so as you've said it's like language
is profoundly shaping not just like our
own mental lives consequences and what
you see on a meditation retreat but you
know world history and whether or not we
tackle something like climate change or
we go to war with Iraq these are really
really big deals and I think that we
have to gain literacy for our minds
Meena I actually think I mean this is
kind of the essence of our work now is
that you know fundamentally we're at
this point where if we can't see our own
psychological you know what's the words
I mean if we can't see the way our minds
are structuring information and we are
just simply as you said before you know
like run by them like they're the
automatic process that runs ahead of our
choices then it's already done like it's
already checkmate because we're already
you know being led by things that don't
produce you no choice making that averts
the kind of catastrophes that I think
that we we all want to avert and I think
this is you know my co-founder of the
Center for you mean technology is a
Raskin says the way to win the final war
is to make peace with ourselves that
this is the architecture like this is
how we work and the only way we're gonna
you know I to get over ourselves and you
know take those risks to make the
choices we want to make in our own lives
is by understanding ourselves better and
the only way we're gonna solve
civilizations problems is by you know
gaining an understanding for the things
that would stand in our way I agree and
we're gonna we are gonna segue to a
technology very very briefly I want to
again encourage people to as a way to
become more familiar with the words that
you are using in the language you're
using which is basically this it you
could think of it as the software that
you're running in in a sense which is
really important like you might want to
inspect that code yeah is to take a look
at Byron Katie's the work and the the 21
day no complaint experiment it's also a
great way by focusing on one particular
category of language to become meta
aware more broadly of the what the voice
in your head is actually telling you all
day long
and technology let's talk about how you
first came to know BJ Fogg
Anna may be this may be this is a place
to start and then we can we can leapfrog
all over the place from there who is BJ
Fogg sure and and do you know BJ by the
way just curious I do I haven't spent
time with him in years but there was a
period of time when I was living in
Mountain View that that we had a chance
to spend a decent amount of time
together and we have spent some time
together we just have actually recently
started emailing again oh cool yeah yeah
so BJ is a psychology professor at
Stanford and he ran something I think
continues to run something called the
Stanford persuasive technology lab that
basically applies everything we know
about the psychology
persuasion to technology and basically
you're asking the question in the lab
how can technology persuade people's
attitudes beliefs and behaviors and you
know a lot of alumni have come out of
this lab I mean I was um project
partners with the co-founder of
Instagram my creature you know a lot of
people went on to work at LinkedIn and
Facebook and the early social media
companies because you know this was like
the perfect set of tools to apply to the
way that we design technology but in the
lab you know you study everything from
clicker training for dogs you know how
do you know what to train a dog to do
the behaviors you want and not the ones
you don't want we read a book called
don't shoot the dog by Karen Pryor
amazing bomb amazing yes you know this
one oh yes I do yeah yeah I do it I
recommend to everyone yeah it's funny I
mean it's like I programmed myself to
enjoy boxing and kickboxing because I
just get a smoothie right afterwards is
that our Pavlovian conditioning click a
clicker train in the form of a smoothie
and it's you learned that you learn
social psychological dynamics some
herbage eldini I mean a lot of the
marketing stuff that you have already
pointed out to so many of your listeners
I'm sure but you know it's really just a
study again of the code this is like
delving into the code of the human mind
and this is what we find persuasive and
I you know this is in 2006 so it's the
year before the iPhone so the iPhone
hasn't hadn't even come out yet and we
had a class on you know persuasion
through video and through mobile apps
and the founder of Instagram and I
before he had anything close to it the
idea for Instagram we worked on you know
applying these principles for good
that's something people get wrong about
the lab they think it was this sort of
diabolical training ground evil
psychological manipulation tech leaders
or something like that
and it wasn't that way at all it was
actually a really powerful you know
three hours once a week deep dive into
this this world and asking a question
how would you use it for good so that
the founder of Instagram and I worked on
this thing called send the sunshine
where you know we thought well what if
we could persuade people in a way that
alleviated depression but using our
social psychology and so this is again
before the iPhone so imagine the kind of
thoughts we'd had to be thinking back
then but you know the idea was imagine
there's some server that knows that the
two friends who are friends and they
have both their phone numbers and it
tracks the zip code of one phone number
and realizes that you've been in a place
you know with bad weather for six days
in a row and because we know from
seasonal affective depression disorder
that's a big deal just having bad
weather for a while can kind of put
someone down and so what if upon hitting
that that condition it then sends a text
message through something like a Twilio
to your units before 2002 and sends it
to your friend Mike and says hey would
you would you take a photo of the
sunshine and send it to your friend
Tristana who's had bad bad weather and
the ideas we just be sending each other
the sunshine and this was a really nice
idea behind the levy aiding alleviating
depression there's all sorts of positive
applications like that we thought of
around helping people go to the gym and
meet their goals and BJ has this nice
model for behavior equals ma TB equals
ma T which is behavior equals motivation
times ability times trigger so someone
whether or not someone does a desired
behavior like going to the gym involves
them being first motivated then having
the ability like do they have you know
if they're trying to go to a boxing
class do they have you know pair of
boxing gloves and you know the clothes
and the shoes or do they are they
staying with a friend where they don't
have those things so they have the
second ability and then the third is is
there a trigger is there like an
opportunity is there a moment is there a
snap the fingers is there a deal and
your smartphone is there a reason why
right now you should consider doing that
behavior and if you have all three of
those things aligned then people will do
it so you know all these kinds of things
but you know this also became relevant
in the story about Cambridge analytic
because I remember back in that in that
class there was one student group that
actually had done there was one segment
in the class on the future of persuasive
technology and ethical persuasive
technology and there was one group that
came up with the idea well what if in
the future you had a profile on every
single person on earth and the profile
was specifically what does their mind
respond to that is persuasive like what
how is their mind uniquely you know
what's their map and what's their what
are their set of psychological biases
like if you said well Harvard really you
know said the Harvard School of
Medicine's
that this thing that's true you know
that would be persuasive for them
because appeals to Authority work with
them or if for you Tim I said hey you
know Eric Weinstein said X Y & Z you
know we both Merritt Weinstein he's a
really smart guy yeah you know each of
us are responsive to different stimuli
and what if in the future you had this
map of what is perfectly persuasive to
each person and then we built technology
that would automate persuasive messages
based on your unique characteristics and
this is actually exactly what Cambridge
analytic a layer was right it uses your
Big Five personality traits if you don't
know the Big Five framework it's your
openness it's the ocean
so it's openness conscientiousness
agreeableness extraversion I got this
two reversed and then neuroticism and so
open yeah I won't go into the details
but basically based on your personality
traits you would deliver different
political messages and that's what
happened in the 2016 election you know
so this all relates to the conversation
we just had about language and about you
know Byron Katie and beliefs it's
because once you understand the code and
you can dip into the code it it's also
it's incredibly dangerous what you can
do with that because if you think about
what do you do when you wake up in the
morning it's the product of what's
running the software that's running
inside you're between your ears and this
is this is the kind of stuff that we
studied in BJ's lab so I have so many
things super super helpful background
BJ's a good guy I just want to just to
reiterate something you said which is
this is not dr. Evil's lair for
malevolent twenty-year-old you know the
code Wizards it in a BGA actually in
other classes focused on things like
peace and world peace and it's difficult
to get people this is a great example of
language it was very difficult for to
get people to agree on what that
actually meant yeah so he would focus on
defining antecedents what are some
components antecedents that would be
necessary to lead to what anyone in the
class would consider world peace in the
knee was able to get people to agree on
some of the the
the smaller antecedents and that ended
up being the focus of the class right it
was very smart way to approach it he's a
good guy so I want to underscore that
and he'd just add on to what you're
saying I mean do you know that the full
story the peace thing was awesome he
actually had for a while back in I think
was two thousand six or seven multiple
tech companies start a peace dot domain
so it was like peace dot facebook.com/
peace that link did gone up surfing calm
yeah he petitioned a few of the tech
companies and the idea was could they
each do something that would be the way
that they are contributing to world
peace and so with Facebook they had a
running wall of new friendships and
connections formed between Israelis and
Palestinians it was it was like a live
feed of how many new relationships had
formed in the last you know whatever a
day or something like that
and couchsurfing the CTO of couchsurfing
actually was my collaborator on this
time well-spent
initiative which later we'll talk maybe
about took over Facebook and Apple and
Google in terms of some recent changes
that they've been making to their
products you know he had started
couchsurfing I worked on couchsurfing
which was a website before Airbnb for
finding free space to crash out when
you're trying to stay with a friend and
they also were part of this Peace
Initiative that BJ started and they
showed I think the number of people who
would stayed in each other's couches
that were also from different ethnic
backgrounds that that would have been
otherwise at war or something like that
and so to bj's credit and so people
really understand and get this it was
not a diabolical dr. evil lab for
training you know psychological
manipulation it was you know explaining
the techniques and he also petitioned
the FTC in the late 1990s about at the
ethics and the need for ethics and
persuasive technology but I just want to
make sure people got that before we go
go deeper yeah and and on the top of
that or just to add to that you know
technologies are tools and tools of
almost any type can be used misused
abused that can be applied in many
different ways and you know one of the
one of the questions I've been kind of
dying to ask you is focused on
incentives I mean we have so many
different direction we could go with
this conversation but ultimately when
I've read a lot of of what you've
written what I've listened to you speak
it becomes clear that at least to me
that much like the quote you you
sometimes use from socio biologists Yeoh
Wilson a quote the real problem of
humanity is the following we have
Paleolithic emotions medieval
institutions and godlike technology
right then to this this this
hypothetical situation that was a more
of a thought experiment or a question
from students in bjs class then
manifested in a political campaign yeah
it can really paint a foreboding picture
of the future right this very dystopian
picture and what I would I'd love to
hear from you as we as we look at some
of the the risks involved we worked it
where companies who are who are fueled
and driven by advertising based models
have cognitive neuroscientists PhDs I
mean armies of highly intelligent
trained people developing highly
intelligent trainable technology to
predict us better than we can predict
ourselves yeah how do you incentivize
companies engineers etc to do the right
thing if and I mean it's presumptive to
say that I know what the right thing is
but let's just say that if for the sake
only one right thing yeah let's just say
for the sake of argument that we agree
that as you've noted or at least the
data reflects I mean let me find it here
because I have a note here that just
it's like horrifying when I look at it
here we go so few examples right sit and
feel free to fact fact check any of this
stuff but with over a billion hours on
YouTube watch daily seventy percent are
from the recommendation system the most
recommended keywords in recommended
videos were get schooled shreds debunks
dismantles debates rips can
grunts destroys hates demolishes right
so we have this extremism reflected in
yeah technology which which we could
talk you mean we could talk about
whether that's a reflection of or
informing the you know mass behavior but
the ones that really paint a terrifying
picture for me I'll only give two
examples but 2018 if you were a teen
girl starting on a dieting video
YouTube's algorithm recommend to
anorexia videos next because those were
better at keeping attention and then one
more this was from a New York Times
articles adults watching sexual content
were recommended videos that
increasingly featured young women then
girls too then children playing in
bathing suits I mean it's like oh it's
it's really it can paint a horrifying
terrifying picture at the same time I
know people who work at all these big
companies as you do and yeah on a
one-on-one basis these are good people
the yeah but the business models sort of
the incentives to shareholders and so on
are such that these seem like very
almost kind of predictable side effects
like perverse side effects of the
incentives that are in place so how do
you how do you incentivize people to
change this who are kind of at the at
this at the driving you know in the
driver's seat putting these things
together yeah well I'm still glad you
laid all that out because I mean that is
what you've last said there which is
that we shouldn't even be surprised by
these consequences I mean they're the
direct consequences you know we always
say it's like these harms are not by
accident they're by design they're not
by designed by the people like you said
the good people who are say there's no
one in facebook who's like hey how do we
your YouTube were like how do we make
this recommend as many pedophilia style
rabbit-hole videos as we can or let's
recommend white nationalism or let's
recommend you know hate you know the
most extreme sort of hate inducing
speech that is not what any one of these
companies wakes up and does but we have
to recognize this race to the bottom of
the brainstem race to the deepest
Paleolithic instincts towards tribal
warfare tide you know towards
survival we're under attack the other
side's gonna come get us we got to get
those immigrants this is our nature and
a race for attention is a race to get
consequences and you have to you know
resonate at a deeper level than the
other guys and so the game theory
progresses so that you have to go deeper
into social validation you have to go
deeper into self-worth you have to go
deeper into tribal warfare language and
so just just a first lay out that you
know these consequences are printable
and direct consequence of that business
model I say the business model we should
also be clear it's not like the
advertising business model causes this
it's not it's not the rectangle that is
the ad the Nike shoes that are causing
outrage and polarization it's more the
engagement business model the fact that
I am NOT as YouTube or Facebook a
neutral tool waiting here like a hammer
waiting to be used at you know just when
you want me I actually have a necessity
I'm like a hammer sitting here with the
stock price that depends on you using me
in particular ways towards particular
nails that cause other hammers to be
activated so that other people keep
using it and I have 500 billion dollars
at stake at keeping people using these
hammers in particular ways and that is
the disincentive that is the subversion
of autonomy that is you know directly
coupled with the success of the product
the success of the business model and
the subversion of the social fabric
unfortunately and so in terms of your
question for the first thing I want to
do is to make sure that we're all clear
on that consequence being you know
direct from falling out of the business
model because you know I've been working
in this for this field for a long time
and it's taken a while for the world to
accept that that is the case I mean at
the beginning I had conversations with
people at some of these big attention
engagements seeking companies you know
five six years ago saying hey I think
you know the business model here is
addiction that business model here is
whatever works at getting attention
they're like yeah you might be right but
indie culture will wake up and see that
on their own there is never a sense of
responsibility in the part of some of
those people and I think that's part of
what we've had to do is make it utterly
clear that this business model does
cause predictable harms
at scales that are really hard to fathom
but no comes the question of like okay
so now we recognize that what do we
actually want to do about it and you
know I think anybody let you know like
you you were here in Silicon Valley 20
years ago and I think how long were you
you were it was like 15 years ago you
were I was I was in Silicon Valley from
2002 onwards up until about a year and a
half ago okay right in the center you
know yeah the 2000 P ria de 2010 ish you
were you were in the thick of it I was
hmm yeah
and I think you know the point being
that all people I know in the founders
of Instagram and you know my friend is
they're asking who you know was early at
Mozilla and started the center free main
technology with me I mean we we all got
in the industry not because we wanted to
to create big I don't know I mean this
is unusual but we actually wanted just
to help people we wanted to build really
empowering tools technology that's more
like a cello you know go back to the
days of the Macintosh words it's a
bicycle for the mind you know the whole
point of what what a computer was and
Steve Jobs idea was and if you take a
human being and they've got their own
locomotive capacity to expend some
energy and then move a certain distance
and they're not very efficient compared
to the Condor but if you give them a
bicycle suddenly a human can like use a
little bit of energy with their legs and
the pedals and they're going further
than a Condor in terms of the locomotive
efficiency and so his metaphor was
technology could be a bicycle for the
mind and I'm all for that and that's
what so many of us got into this
industry to do but then somewhere along
the way you know the the set of
incentives that were at play forced that
the thing we would monetize is human
behavior and that's that's where the the
first problem comes in that success in
the Macintosh was not directly tied to
how many of your friends I could sign up
to using and then getting them clicking
on things and sending you notifications
about when they click this desktop icon
versus that to stop by Konnor there's no
problem with Adobe Photoshop there's no
problem with Microsoft Word Microsoft
Word wasn't tilted in the world towards
conspiracy theories or algorithmic
extremism and sending notifications
about when your friends didn't check the
word document that you did it didn't
send them I mean you didn't have any of
this stuff so the thing that the
fundamental place that we went wrong is
when we attack
financial success directly to the
capturing of human behavior the
controlling and shaping of human
behavior because that's where the
persuasive technology stuff comes in
because those principles became applied
to how do I keep you engaged and so if
you take an example like the follow
button you know if you remember you know
Twitter an Instagram or to the first
services that did this where instead of
just adding someone's a friend which is
the Facebook model a bi-directional
connection model followers that follow
button and model created a reason why
you would always get new email like
every day you get a new email being like
you've got two new followers you've got
five new followers you've got six new
followers and you always want to say oh
I wonder who followed me today and so
that was this beautiful invention that
got people coming back and ultimately to
become addicted to getting attention
from other people and the same thing
with the like button so you know instead
of persuading to get to capture your
attention it was much cheaper to get
people hooked to seeing how much
attention they got from other people
because now you autonomously like I
don't have to do anything to you you are
now autonomously going back to see how
many views did I get on that YouTube
video how many views did I get when I
played that video game and I posted it
on Twitch how many views did I get likes
it I get when I put that post up and so
I think that's that's what we went wrong
is when we tied business success and
billions of dollars to the amount that
we captured attention and we have to go
through a mass decoupling between
business success and capturing human
beings and that's gonna be uncomfortable
transition it's a big transition I think
that's of this scale of you know going
from an extractive energy economy of
fossil fuels to a regenerative energy
economy you know that the metaphor we
make is the resultant there's only so
many environmental resources and
drilling for oil and that that worked
great at generating you know a whole
energy economy that you know gave us all
this a prosperity but now unless we want
to deal with you know climate
catastrophe we got a switch to a
regenerative energy economy that doesn't
directly couple you know profit with
extraction the same thing is he'll
accept the finite substrate that we're
extracting from is our own brains like
we're scooping out
attention from ourselves because it
takes nine months to put a new human
being into the attention economy and and
we have to decouple this relationship
that profit is directly coupled with the
extraction and move it to a more
regenerative model where we are not the
the cow or the or the product but we're
the customer what what might motivate or
force say a Facebook to change their
model in the sense that if you look at
Wall Street which is as a metaphor for
an investment I'm not going to say in it
all investors are amoral that's not true
at all
but a lot of them are somewhat morally
agnostic in the sense that if facebook
can better and better monetize the
capturing of attention this is a
non-renewable resource of the mind yeah
money will flow into Facebook and then
Facebook will be positively reinforced
and rewarded for doing what we're
describing right so how do you how do is
it possible to divert the flow of that
river mean what what would is it going
to take high-level policy change what
what what what levers could be pulled
that would that would catalyze a change
yeah well I think just to name very
concretely what you're pointing out is
that this you know all the incentives
point to continuing this sort of self
extraction I mean so why would we stop
scooping the attention out of ourselves
destroying democracy and debasing our
mental health when that's the thing that
makes the most money in Wall Street's
not going to stop funding it so to
deepen that example you're giving back
last year in August when Facebook
started when Twitter shut down 73
million fake accounts these were you
know what are called sock puppet
accounts or fake accounts I could've
been Russian bods that had been whatever
they should have been rewarded for
taking down these 73 million accounts
but of course what happened when Wall
Street saw this was that their stock
price had previously been tied directly
to how many users they have so when they
gonna take down 73 cent lead accounts
they're like oh well your companies
worth a lot less than before but we
actually had to do the opposite which is
that we need to reward the companies for
basically having a high integrity public
square and there's so many different
facets to this Tim but the to answer
your question we're going to need policy
that basically does you know helps this
decoupling process happen we're going to
need shareholder activism that puts
board resolutions on the companies to
make this change we're going to need
internal employees advocating for this
change saying you know hey I don't I
want to move to a more regenerative
model that's like the equivalent of
people last year advocating for time
well spent which ultimately became part
of the design goal from Mark Zuckerberg
and Facebook in 2018 so it's gonna it's
a transition it's just like moving from
fossil fuels like excellent does not
have an incentive to not be Exxon you
know and sometimes that we wake up and
he's uncomfortable circumstances where
you know our business model is based on
a thing we didn't know was bad at the
time but we're starting to realize it
was bad and you know an uncomfortable
metaphor I've use for this in the past
it's like let's say you run the NFL
National Football League like great
sport we've been doing it for you know
decades and decades and decades and you
know lucky you you're CEO of NFL and one
day you know you're your sports
scientist health guy comes up to you and
says hey I think that only smash
people's heads together like this it's
causing concussions and you just wake up
and realize that your business model is
smashing people's heads together and
selling it against advertising on TV and
it's kind of the essence of the sport
and no one wanted it to be this way but
that's where we landed and now what do
we do and it's really hard I mean
everyone's gonna try to put in the
padding and we're gonna try to increase
safety standards and you do whatever you
can but at some point the essence the
existential essence of what football is
about is that you know is this sort of
process that does endanger people's
people's heads and I think that's a
situation that we're near now which is
that we can't ask for internal change
from companies who whose entire you know
incentives are otherwise but with policy
that decouples success we can talk more
about that but there's some ways to do
it from the outside
I'd love to yeah I'd love to talk more
about this the and this is this is
relatively new territory for me I mean
not as a user but certainly at a policy
level or a sort of replacing business
model perspective with some of these
these these gigantic companies you have
far more time in the trenches than I do
is is what what are any of the kind of
Archimedes levers are proof points that
could cause a shift if any such thing
could exist for example is there a
company that is pursuing a different
model though they could use the
extraction or the attention extraction
model who if they succeed on a large
scale could be get a rail of similar
companies or provoke a change in
business model at some of these other
companies and are there any particular
that you know models to mimic or
companies that are doing something that
that were that reflects a viable
alternative or or is it really just
blank canvas at this point yeah I mean
we're in uncharted territory because we
have this situation where there's a
monopoly on a tension between you know a
handful of major technology companies
Facebook Twitter YouTube you know
snapchat Instagram whatsapp kind of own
the attentional environment and there
aren't an alternative place to reach
10,000 people when you want to upload a
video right you can't just get that same
level of audience when you push it to
Vimeo and so these are a kind of
attention monopolies which is why one of
the issues and one of the fundamental
things we got to deal with is
competition we one reason we're not
getting different business models is you
can't compete and get access to that
same attention monopoly so we we need
this way you know Chris Hughes the
Facebook co-founder writing that op-ed
in the New York Times saying we have to
break up Facebook is there needs to be
more diverse ways of people competing to
produce products that are of different
business models that support society's
well-being that better protect the
public square but then the respond
from the tech companies is gonna be I
think Zuckerberg said that you know they
spend more money on protection and Trust
and abuse and Russian misinformation
protection and you know Trust in safety
and all that stuff then all of Twitter's
revenue combined so like take all of
total revenue a year and they spend more
money on that then on trust and safety
than what Twitter spends in a year on
ever what they gain in a year on revenue
so that but this isn't in this
uncomfortable position where it's gonna
cost us something we can't just do it
you know this is kind of like a non I
forget his last name but the book the
winner-take-all you know it's we keep
looking for these win-win solutions but
sometimes we have to lose a little bit
so that everybody wins and that's not a
good message for you know capitalists
because that's not how we like to roll
but you know sometimes it works that way
with organic food right like you realize
that maybe regular food isn't so good
and we want to get the clown food that's
better that's organic it doesn't have
the same pollutants you know there's
some marketing and narrative that's
baked into that assumption and we can
sell it for a higher price so the thing
that's good for people we can actually
make money off of in a premium product
but in this world these are the products
that run the public square that run the
world belief system so talking about
beliefs the first you know however long
we were talking just consider that
YouTube shapes more than a billion hours
of watch time daily and there's two
billion people which is who use it every
day which is about more than the size of
Christianity in terms of a psychological
footprint YouTube that Facebook is 2.3
billion people YouTube is 2 billion
people if you add up Instagram and
whatsapp it's another billion or so so
you're talking about couple
Christianity's of psychological
influence total this is an insane level
of psychological influence so we better
be really thoughtful this is why I think
you know I my for my background I mean
where I look at these things from is
let's get really nuanced and hold up a
microscope to what these things are
doing to the psychological timelines of
people you know what happens in your
nervous system whether it's with the
word climate change how the word death
tax or the word you know send our sons
and daughters to war you know between
you know two billion people going down a
railway where if you pull the lever they
experience
these setup consequences on YouTube and
if you don't pull the lever they
experience these set of consequences
that's like the trolley problem in
philosophy that's kind of what I was
thinking about when I was at Google as a
design at the Syst is how do you shape
two billion people's thoughts where you
don't even really get to make that
ethical decision because your business
model and your incentives are making
that decision for you and this is where
we have to decouple it then we can talk
about some concrete solutions I mean
Apple by the way is kind of the
government of the attention economy
they're like the central bank and they
people don't look at them that way
because they're just making this product
called the iPhone but they control the
dials on basically what it means to get
attention from people and and where that
you know the App Store Policies on
business models and you know things like
screen time that help you limit how much
time you're spending there are ways in
which from top down you can change the
incentives or juice of quantitative
easing on you know how people navigate
through an incentive system that's
fundamentally about manipulating their
attention but then there's some deeper
changes that we can talk about to yeah
let's get into it
what are some what are some deeper
changes I like the sound of it sort of
giving you an opening here I'll swing it
this side the soft pitch I'll take it
yeah jump in the the one simple example
is what happened with energy companies
and utilities in the United States so it
used to be if you think about it energy
companies make more money the more
energy you use so technically you know
if they're running out of profits and
they want you to use more they're
incentivized to have you leave the
lights on leave the faucet on leave the
shower on just waste as much energy as
possible because that's how they rake in
the money right right mm-hmm
okay so and clearly that's not right
like you don't want a world where we're
basically we profit from our own
self-destruction except that's kind of
what we're trying to avoid here in all
the circumstances so what happened with
energy is at least four I think at least
half of US states went through this
decoupling regulation where energy
companies profit the more energy you use
linearly so you use a little bit more
energy it makes some more money more
energy that make some more money and
then at some point you hit a tier where
they wanted disincentivizing you they
want to disincentivize you from using
more
so they say double charge zero so now
use the same amount of energy but now
they're charging you twice as much so
that disincentivizes you from using it
except they don't hold on to all of the
profits from that 2x cost they instead
reinvest that extra cost into a
renewable fund a fund that basically
invests in renewable energy
infrastructure so in other words the
disincentive to use more energy is used
to fund the transition to renewable
energy right and now you can imagine
something similar happening with
technology where you can have an
attention or advertising based business
MA I'm not saying this is the solution I
believe in by the way but I think this
is a you know a piece in the toolkit is
you can have a situation where you make
money the more attention you get from
someone but up until a very small point
because beyond that point you're
basically incentivized to create
mindless consumption and zombification
and teen mental health problems and
loneliness and the whole thing right so
you can imagine a world where we
decouple attention success from business
success decouple the capturing of human
behavior and manipulation of human
behavior from business success and then
most importantly to reinvest that money
into you know the equivalent of what
renewable attention renewable human life
you know things would look like and that
that could happen that's something that
you could help regulate with with laws
you know ask I'm sorry
yeah Paul Romer go ahead Paul Romer yeah
use a Nobel Prize many economists had
proposed something recently called like
an attention data tax that has some
similar characteristics that you want to
progressively price the attention
companies because they have this this
bad incentive where would you if it were
up to you where would you apply those
funds so I mean in the long run I think
that you can't have you know I said this
on you know some other things I mean I
you know I know you've had Marc
Andreessen on the on the podcast and he
has this this line that's pretty famous
from 2011 that software is eating the
world right because fundamentally it's
like okay if you could have taxis in our
whole transportation infrastructure
run without software or and it's not
done with any intelligence and there's
no demand side Matthew no supply
matching etc first you do it with
technology and you get all that
efficiency of course software's gonna
eat the world it's gonna eat up
everything it's gonna eat up media it's
gonna eat up advertising it's gonna eat
up taxis and transportation it's gonna
eat up every domain of life because it
can always do it more efficiently mm-hmm
but if you think about it what that
means is take a morning take an area
like Saturday morning cartoons so that
used to be run not by software used to
be run by some human beings and some
laws and editors QA ting what happens
for children but then you let YouTube
for YouTube just gobble up saddled
Saturday morning and it also gobbles up
with it all of the Saturday morning
protections and so as software eats the
world like for example Facebook you know
we used to have equal price campaign ads
on on TV as regulated so it's Tuesday
night at 7:00 p.m. it should cost the
same amount for Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump to reach the same audience
otherwise it'd be unfair we wouldn't be
in democracy but you suddenly let
Facebook gobble up election advertising
and now the price has no assurances that
it's going to be the same equal price so
what happens is as software starts
eating the world what happens is private
incentives eat the world we lose the
public protections so to answer your
question about where it goes for
renewable funds is we have to have some
notion of things that are built to serve
the public interest and not just private
interests I know this is happening in
some discussions around AI we're passed
a certain amount of wealth creation
because these AI things once you really
let them go can generate so much wealth
by continuing to produce innovations and
efficiencies and revenue and all this
stuff that you know after some certain
point we just give that money back to
the people you know give that money back
to instead of extracting from us
shouldn't it be ultimately for improving
the greater lot for all of society and I
think that's something that we may feel
uncomfortable with but we have to do
with these large technology companies
because if they're running a constant
for-profit shareholder maximizing
extraction
you know racket and they've got to keep
maximizing and they've got to keep
extracting they there's never a point to
the end of their growth
it's no wonder that they're over
extracting from democracy and mental
health and kids and all this other stuff
if they have to keep growing their
formative attention I suppose also I
mean this is just me kind of talking out
my ass for a second but it's go for it
bad habit I have so here we go if even
if one can't settle on a plausible
alternative there could be a reasonable
consensus on the undesirable side
effects of the model right so you could
as a stopgap measure say a portion of
funds past this point and it would be
tricky to define whatever that point is
is applied to say some mechanism for
trying to alleviate teen mental health
issues let's just say or fill in the
blank right to try to offset the damage
that is being done at the very least and
that could be you know at least a a
possible discussion for a plausible
stopgap until a viable supplemental
model or alternative model is found
towards which things get steered through
some type of suppose it would have to be
policy or regulation or something along
those lines
yeah well what I hear you saying
fundamentally is about um you know this
is a classic externalized externalizing
harm model right like you know so oil is
the most profitable you know form of
creating energy and moving around the
world and you know portable and all
these great things but it so it makes
the most economic sense to go with oil
except if you account for the
externalities
if you account for the balance sheet of
society the balance sheet of the Commons
a balance sheet of nature which get hurt
by this seemingly most efficient
cheapest form of energy and the same
thing is true of advertising like it
feels like well why in the world would
we you and I can pay for Facebook when
it's free I mean while it wouldn't like
the problems the harm shows up on the
balance sheet of you know our sleep of
our of our collective democracy of our
public's fear of the quality of our
sense making
the information ecology mental health it
shows up everywhere and so what I hear
you saying is hey well let's at least
put a fund aside to pay for some of
those externalities almost like carbon
offsets or mental-health offsets or the
metrics the offsets but the challenge is
that you know it's like wouldn't it be
better it's like there's this joke about
capitalism it's like capitalism would
prefer to give you diabetes and then get
you subscribed to a profit maximizing
diabetes cure that I keep you know on a
subscription where I make money yes I
sell you the subscription for the
solution versus just not creating the
diabetes at all in the first place right
yeah and I think the question is how do
we create systems that don't create the
diabetes the informational diabetes the
democracy diabetes the mental health
diabetes with technology in us how do we
not do that in the first place and by
the way it's totally possible
like you know Instagram at the very
beginning I remember when those guys
first started and I was one of the early
users because we actually used was it
called bourbon was the first Assessor to
Instagram and I used to be just about
friends keeping up with each other's
lives and it had some addictive
qualities and you know had some of the
infinite scroll and all that stuff but
it didn't have this focus on celebrities
and girls who basically competed on who
would wear that you know fewer clothing
and then be most recommend in the
discover tab you know to get maximum
audience and then kids basically
realizing they could make money and
selling their Instagram page for the
million followers to brands and that
everyone wanting to be compete and being
a bigger influencer like all that
culture of we're all addicted to being
influencer isn't dicted to getting
attention that is an externality of
culture of cultural values that are not
real but that actually came from
Instagram going down this over
extractive kind of growth oriented path
that you know that that they needed to
not because you know they're evil people
or anything like that but because the
the business model once they are
acquired by Facebook they had to keep
growing they had to get a bigger and
bigger attentional footprint and what
you wouldn't want is you want it back to
the early days I mean let's take it back
to the and the Instagram guys and just
following ten friends and seeing where
they are in the world and keeping in
touch with our friends that's great you
know and there's people who use
Instagram that way now and that's also
awesome but we also have to account for
the fact that the interface is not tuned
towards keeping it just for that use
case like Instagram could be if it was
truly humane
just trying to you know help us pick
those 10 friends that we really want to
keep in touch with as opposed to let's
maximize discovery and influencers and
you know millions of followers and get
lots of people looking at stuff that's
that's an incentive of a for-profit
public company that now has to run that
incentive and you know the same thing
was true with Facebook by the way if you
go back to early interviews with
Zuckerberg in 2005 at Stanford he gives
a speech at Stanford with Jim Brier the
entrepreneurial thought leaders seminar
and he said you know what is Facebook
and he said it's it's like an address
book it's like a public it's like a
utility for your social life it's a
social utility is what he called it and
that was closer to a model where it's
more of a tool back to what you were
saying about technology being just a
tool like I'm I'm all of that I mean
technology being an empowerment tool and
I think there's beautiful things that
can come from these things when they are
operating as tools but the business
model of advertising and engagement is
the anti tool it does not want to be a
tool it wants something from you and
that's what we have to to you know draw
that line there and decouple business
success from not being a tool might
sound aggressive I mean this is the
nails hard like yeah it's tough I mean
this is we're talking about highly you
know systems with extreme financial
rewards associated with the problems
that are manifesting and compounding
right and yes exactly like climate
change there right because it's like you
know we're all addicted to the growth
but like growth towards what growth
towards our own self terminating you
know catastrophe that's like yeah we
can't we can't get off oil because
that's the only way we're gonna get the
thing and it's like yeah but the
alternative is that we have self
terminating endpoint so we have to
recognize that you know it's like Paul
Hawken if you know him and his work on
drawdown it's a it's like at the top 100
ways to to address climate change and he
says well but people tell him like hope
it's calming climate change is so
expensive it's gonna cost us so much
money it's like no it's actually the
opposite way around if we don't do it
it's gonna cost us way more we have to
make the transition towards something
renewable
because it's actually going to be
completely self terminating if we don't
because I you know the the information
ecology the the thing that fuels how we
make sense of the world in our democracy
like democracy only can out-compete the
Chinese authoritarian model if we have
really good bottom-up information
sources like diverse rich ideas
marketplace type things and this
business model of engagement the race to
the bottom of the brainstem towards the
salacious the outrageous the hateful
speech the extremism stuff the
pedophilia is not fueling our democracy
with the best sources it's like we have
to talk about you know personal life
optimization and keto diets and meat you
know you trance-like worker
you ourselves the opposite of a
democracy democracy kilo diet right and
we we have to flip this around and it's
not a matter of this being my opinion or
something like that or this being you
know just being a motivated activist
this is like I'm actually concerned
about this because if we don't the
alternative is a thousand of billion
times worse yeah for sure I
it reminds me of a quote by and I never
know how to pronounce this guy's name
but Chuck Palahniuk I think I'm getting
it right and it's the partial quote his
big brother isn't watching he's singing
and dancing he's pulling rabbits out of
a hat big brothers busy holding your
attention every moment you're awake he's
making sure you're always it distracted
he's making sure you're fully absorbed
and just goes on to say by doing so
you're no threat and I'd want to turn
this into some you know viva la
resistance type of I'll tell you I mean
this represents the new really amusing
ourselves to death by Neil postman I
have not but I have heard of it it's
there's this quote I'm gonna pull it up
because I just worth reading really
quick we're all keeping an eye out for
1984 and you know we we thought about
the dystopia that we would get was the
Big Brother one but alongside Orwell's
dark vision there was this other
slightly older and less well-known but
equally chilling vision of Huxley's
brave new world it's Aldous Huxley and
you know he summarizes this way so it's
beautifully it says what Orwell feared
were those who would ban books
what would Huxley feared is that there
would be no reason to ban
because there would be no one who wanted
to read 100 filled those who would
deprive us of information Huxley feared
those who would give us so much that we
would be reduced to passivity and egoism
Orwell feared that the truth would be
concealed from us Huxley feared the
truth would be drowned in a sea of
irrelevance Orwell feared we would
become a captive culture Huxley feared
we would come a trivial culture
preoccupied with some equivalent of the
Feelies the or deep orgy and the
centrifugal bumble-puppy this is the
1930s as Huxley marked in brave new
world the civil libertarians who were
ever on the alert to opposed he ranee
they failed to take into account man's
almost infinite appetite for
distractions he ends by saying although
feared those that what we feel will ruin
us Huxley feared that what we desire
will ruin us oh and that's that's
essentially the premise of the work it's
like there's two ways to kind of fail
here and as in most systems there's
almost always two ways to fail one will
fail is the authoritarian Big Brother
censorship sort of mode but with so
little information that we don't have
any and we're all restricted and
top-down control etc but then on the
bottom-up way to fail is just
overwhelmed in irrelevance in
distraction in over stimulating our
magic trick sort of brain with
Paleolithic social validation and tribal
warfare and moral outrage and all that
stuff that isn't actually adding up to
anything and human agency which is
unique to the world like choice is that
thing sitting in between those two
worlds
you know informed effective choice good
choice and that's what we right now like
as a human civilization like that's
where we got to be because those other
two models are really bad and in self
terminating in some cases if we cannot I
mean my biggest fear about these issues
is we have to be able to agree on a
common reality a con truth because
that's the only way if you don't agree
on what's real or if I don't believe
there is truth then we can't construct
shared agendas to solve problems like
inequality or climate change or whatever
like we have real problems and we have
to find ways that we actually
can see those agreements and then
construct actions together to change it
and I think that right now a technology
that I'm taking is away from that but
the reason that we work on these topics
is I want to live in a world where
technology is giving us the superpowers
to do that like superpowers for common
ground' superpowers for constructing
shared agendas superpowers for instead
of getting learned helplessness by
seeing climate change news you know
pounded into our nervous systems dosed
to you know to two billion people a day
to instead have you know mass
empowerment like mass coordinated an
action that we can all take and feel
optimistic about all that all the
progress we're making and all that all
the things we can do next so that's
that's kind of the project here is like
we are trapped in this one Paleolithic
meat suit that's got these you know
these kinds of bends and contortions
that have been reality in a way that can
be hacked and we can also use those
bends and contortions in a way that
gives us the most empowerment and if we
ever needed those superpowers it's it's
right now this is a perfect segue I have
I have a question for you that is
personalized and I'm gonna I'm gonna
start by finishing the quote that I
ended up only breeding partially it's a
Big Brother this is from Chuck Palahniuk
Big Brother isn't watching this is very
close to what you were just saying with
Huxley he's singing and dancing he's
pulling rabbits out of a hat Big
Brother's busy holding your attention
every moment you're awake he's making
sure always distracted he's making sure
you're fully absorbed he's making sure
your imagination withers until it's as
useful as your appendix and that would
be a problem both on an individual level
and certainly on a collective level and
there's a there's a quote of yours that
was in the I guess it TEDx Brussels if
I'm getting a location right
presentation I spend a lot of my time
thinking about how to spend my time and
I'd love for you to talk about what you
do on a personal level to whether it's a
firewall your attention or to mitigate
some of the damage slash distraction
that every economic force seems to want
to impose on you and so there's there's
you know on one hand there's
feeding Skynet and then yeah there's
like the day-to-day life of John Connor
right so if you're John Connor like what
what what are some of the things that
you do on a day to day or week to week
basis to defend against some of these
you know some of these forces some of
these some of these technologies it's
funny when you mentioned this sort of
John Connor and both living a personal
life and defeating Skynet I just
realized in you saying that that's
basically both both my life is both of
those things right like that every
single day of my life is how do we
defeat Skynet whether it's on Capitol
Hill and just coming back from that last
week or you know the personal level of
just being being being effective so I'm
well rested so I can do that um you know
it's really hard and part of why I've
worked on these topics for so long I
mean that first TED talk in 2014 was
about time well-spent
and about the power of persuasive
technology to make us distracted which
is kind of how this all started was that
I found myself so easily distracted like
I hated seeing this happen over and over
again like you know you get one of these
emails saying you've been tagged in the
photo or someone commented mentioned to
you in a comment like this is appealing
to really deep instinct like you're the
protagonist of the show called your life
and when someone tags you in a photo
it's like Oh something about me social
proof is in line what did they say is it
good is it bad I have to see right now
and it's really powerful stuff and the
reason that I work on this is because I
actually feel more sensitive than other
people I feel certainly very sensitive
to these forces so it's why I think it's
so important to protect them and I
protect against them and I think of it
like we have to build these like
exoskeletons for our Paleolithic brains
I mean the military kind of takes this
stuff seriously right with you know in
military combat and the the kind of
flight instrumentation you see in the
aircraft military aircraft or something
like that it's all about managing
attention like with crazy levels of
discipline and science and research
about how do you build that exoskeleton
that gives us that level of focus and
and thinking about through the right
questions and not the wrong questions
and being well rested and you know being
able to stay up for many hours and
focused on one single task and
all that so now to conclude the answer
your question what are the things that
we do you know I first of all like I
said I struggle it's hard especially now
because defeating Skynet comes with a
lot of email and communications and it's
like being part of running a social
movement for how to fix these things and
we have a non-profit for those who don't
know called the Center for Humane
Technology where we focus on this and we
get emailed by every major world
government and you know people who are
dying to fix these problems and we're
trying to be of assistance in catalyzing
that change so it comes with a ton of
work and it's and social obligation to
get back to people and but some things
that I've found have been helpful I mean
one thing I've been doing since I was in
college is since we're mentioning these
tips like the grayscale tip which just
to make sure your audience knows what
that is
so that the idea there is when your
phone has colorful rewards it its
invisibly addictive it's like showing
the chimpanzee part of your brain a
banana every single time you you you
look at the color of the icons and all
that stuff and so one thing you can do
is you can go into and I think they're
probably gonna list this in the comments
but it's something like I think it's
general and then if you go to the
Settings app on your iPhone and then
general and then if you scroll to
accessibility you can scroll to the
bottom there's this thing lets you
triple click to set your phone grayscale
and so you say why would I so I set my
phone in grayscale well it just strips
out those color rewards so now when you
look at your phone it doesn't have that
just just a little bit less lustre and
psychological animation of your nervous
system and we helped popularize that and
it's mostly also for the social effect
cuz when you do that people say I don't
your phone's grayscale why is that
happening and then lets you tell the
story about why you would do this and
the attention economy and if you heard
about time well-spent that's kind of why
we did that
quick quick quick addendum on that so
the triple click can turn it grayscale
and back to color I now put that I'll
put that in the show notes so people can
find that at Tim dialogue forward slash
podcast the the another benefit of that
which is which is one way to sell it is
or an additional way to sell it is that
it increases battery life also yes
quite substantially increases battery
life and it makes it harder to find your
icons which might view as a bug but it's
a feature if you're trying to use social
media less yeah well so that speaks to a
secondary thing that you know I've
recommended for a while which is
thinking that your phone is you know
there's like a filter or other it's it's
unfiltered so it accepts both
unconscious mindless uses of it and
conscious mindful uses of it and it
can't tell the difference between when
you're a zombie and you're out of
anxiety reaching for it to just check
again the thing you already checked 10
seconds ago and when you're actually
saying no no I really need to find
directions to that party I'm going to I
need to find those directions right now
right it can't tell so you don't want to
put up these arbitrary speed bumps or
roadblocks between you and what you want
generically because then you can't
distinguish between those two uses so
another thing you can do is if you
basically take off all of your your apps
from your home screen almost all of them
except for the we recommend we call them
the tools so like tools or your quick in
and out utilities things like calendar
things like lyft or uber things like you
know messages that just let you quickly
do something and then you're done so
those are fine to have on your home
screen but he moved everything else off
the home screen and instead train
yourself to pull down from the top on an
iPhone and type like I want to launch
mail or I want to launch Instagram or I
want to launch Twitter because if you
type you have to be making more of a
conscious choice because like that it's
that's great so think that is like
you're putting like a a band pass filter
between you and your film that's only
accepting conscious uses and rejecting
mindless uses so that's like another
thing you can do another thing that I do
if you want to be really militant about
it is if you think about one of the
problems with the way that phones
vibrate it's gotten so bad that we now
experience this thing called phantom
vibrations where we believe that our
phone is vibrated even when it hasn't
and we're we're stimulated so often that
we're just constantly you know reaching
in our baggage to feel if it actually
did vibrating check it again just in
case and it's just a mess and one of the
things that would help alleviate this is
if you have a custom vibration signature
for different kinds of notifications
for example when I get a message through
iMessage from from a contact I actually
it buzzes three times in quick
succession like business like really
fast and I can tell therefore when I'm
getting a message from someone versus
when I'm getting like a calendar
notification like you're ten minutes
late for Tim's interview and that is it
is it helpful thing cuz if you think
about it your phone is like a slot
machine it's buzzing in the same
ambiguous way every time which forces
you to say oh I wonder if that could be
that thing I was looking for and then
that's the excuse to get sucked in and
then you get sucked into the rest of the
things so in general you want to
minimize your your use of of you know
meet your meeting to even check the
thing in the first place and that's what
that helps do and so you can do that by
going to your notifications and
unfortunately apple doesn't let you
split up all of your your your major
categories of notifications I mean this
is why when we push on technology
companies and this is one way Apple
could be like a better government a
better central bank is if they enable in
the next version of the phone a thing
that showed you basically here are the
top three kinds of notifications that
you're getting like he was like a
continent map of the major five
categories of notifications do you want
to set up a unique buzz signature for
each of these five to distinguish them
yeah or disable them right exactly so I
mean both and in the whole point is we
should have a whole this is like the
environmental movement right it's like
imagine there's this this is the thing
we're trying to catalyze is that if
everybody treated human attention as
something sacred that we're trying to
minimize our footprint on it as opposed
to maximize how much we manipulate take
extract scoop out of your nervous system
um that's the fundamental change and if
we treat it if everything was treating
your attention as something sacred that
like we want to move and change the
minimal number of pixels on your screen
we want the minimal number of vibrations
to ever occur we want the minimal number
of psychological anxiety concerns I mean
this is another category people will
talk about is even when you're not
looking at the phone the anxiety loops
of concerns that are looping in your
mind as a result of the 10 minutes ago
when you were using your phone like oh
did that person get back to me oh I
wonder if I got new likes on that thing
oh I wonder if I'm
get the address for that event you know
they sent that yet um those ways in
which the phones could silence those
concerns by for example letting us set
up a like let's say when you go and do
not disturb for two hours it said is
there any give you the option to say is
there anyone who if you heard from them
in the next two to three hours you would
want it to make a special noise for and
you could mark that out and that way you
can out you can now not use the phone
and have complete like separation from
it because you have this certain TV you
won't miss something important because
that fear that we could miss something
important is really powerful so that
even when you go on Do Not Disturb for
her plane mode people still go back to
their phones when they check so I think
people just don't really realize the
extent to which their deeper level
nervous system and habits for reaching
for this thing have been hijacked and
this is about kind of unhide jacking
your whole nervous system not just you
know the way that the phone works but
kind of alleviating and releasing your
whole nervous system from its deep
connection to these expectations yeah
totally and it's it's it's the effect on
the nervous system right like the actual
biological cost is is something that is
hard to fully take stock of until it's
removed and it's huge and I at least
once every six months trying to go a few
weeks without any use of of social media
and I find it I find it useful I find it
fun I enjoy connecting with people
through Twitter and polling and there
are some fantastic uses of social media
and I enjoy looking at it pretty
pictures on Instagram of cabins that I'm
sure I will never visit and things like
this but the there there is a like
neurobiological cost and one way one
thing that I do that that people might
also consider is if if you feel like you
absolutely can't survive without social
media or maybe that type of sentiment is
disguised as I need this for my career
in a B and C ways or I need this for my
company in a B or C ways there are many
instances where I will schedule using
something like buffer or Edgar or one of
these other tools
for several weeks so I'll batch my
taking a photographs those or whatever
might be have those scheduled out for a
few weeks and I give myself than a
vacation from any type of active
monitoring or responding to social media
and the feeling at the tail end of that
let's call it week or two weeks most
pronounced after a week is not that this
is gonna sound really maybe ridiculous
but it is not that dissimilar from a
seven-day silent Vipassana retreat it is
such a deal OD'ing phase yeah that it's
it's it's it sounds unbelievable until
you actually try it totally I mean I
think what you're speaking to in general
is something that we would call it
humane technology design pattern wishes
you you know the there are going to be
moments when we think of a thing we need
to do and the inability to do it at that
moment leads us to have to open up
Twitter and and write that thing or send
that email to ourselves or whatever and
it you know it if we can't do it then
when we have to leave it on our nervous
system as a looping concern so now for
the rest of your day until you get to a
computer or whatever until you do
it's like looping and you like don't
forget this ain't over dancing and
there's a way in which if technology
we're truly respecting you know the fact
that we're better off offloading these
things into somewhere else or it's not
taxing our nervous system it could be a
universal design pattern that you could
enter something you want to do and
schedule when you want it to happen and
not do it immediately whether it's
sending an email to someone or sending a
you know the text message when you're
like I think the way the iMessage thing
works on an iPhone you send a message to
someone while you're on airplane mode
but it won't just say oh I'll send this
when you get back I just won't send it
and it forces it to be on you to go back
to such a pace say this yeah and imagine
if it said like hey when do you want
this thing to send it's like baked into
the way iMessage works right yeah when
we're glide into / like Gmail offline
right it would it would automatically
send when you're connected as opposed to
forcing you to go in click on this
exclamation mark and confirm that you
resent its like yeah I do want to resend
it because clearly didn't get delivered
the first time this should be pretty
easy to logically deduce and and you
have to have the certainty that it's
gonna work because if you don't have the
certainty even if it does work like 90%
of the time like it's gonna generate
that extra layer of like an anxious
timeline like just imagine this anxious
timeline plopped down into your nervous
system so that for the next two hours
there's this extra 3% that your dermis
system is just taxed by the fact that
you're not sure for sure if this thing
sent like you know Gmail supposed to
send it because it was an offline mode
and they promise that they will but if
you don't have that certainty you know
that we have to have that kind of
confidence and I think this is actually
one of the simplest things that
technology could do is there's a lot of
uncertainty about stuff just doesn't
work consistently you know like yeah a
lot of this a lot of the the stress and
the background radiation of anxiety
would go down if we just had more
consistency in the way that we believed
that these things would would work as
opposed to yeah the ways that they are
periodically broken I mean another one I
wanted to mention that I do in terms of
creating a fortress or firewall of
attention I actually haven't talked
about this one but if you turn on um in
accessibility settings on a Mac the zoom
feature and if you ever use this but you
can like zoom in to a certain part of
the screen yeah
and I do it where you hold down the ctrl
key and then you just use two fingers to
sort of zoom in and zoom out but what I
do is when I'm trying to write for
example I easily get distracted by any
other pixels that happen to pop into the
screen like it really affects me I'm
hypersensitive and so when I'm doing any
writing I'll just zoom into that text
field so it actually occupies the full
15 inches of my macbook pro screen and
it helps me really focus and using
things like that if you if you just
imagine that I'm trying you're literally
trying to conserve the number of pixels
that change in an unexpected way because
that will hijack and make it easier to
forget or otherwise detour you from
something that you're doing and all of
us again is like currently on us to do
this is like this extra cost that we all
have to pay to know these tricks and
listen to these podcasts and
you know fiddle with these settings a
hundred times but the whole premise of
this kind of work is imagine a humane
and regenerative world where this is how
it works by default where everything is
trying to minimize its footprint on our
attention and air all the defaults are
set to make it as seamless as possible
and to do it the way that you would want
it to work and to not have to double
think and think oh maybe did it send I
gotta send that again just that
certainty that I can actually have peace
of mind I can actually do not disturb
for a day because I know that you know
out of office messages or I'm not gonna
respond for two days to email was built
into the native functioning of how email
worked on every email app or messaging
app right we don't you don't get that
chance to hear they don't get in what
set doesn't have a mode that says hey I
want to go on vacation for a week and
this is the message I want to send to
the people that are in this class of
contacts like that could be baked into
the way that messaging works the ability
to disconnect without missing something
important and that's the premise of what
has to happen is a deeper redesign that
treats human attention as sacred and
that treats our cognition as something
that we need to conserve for the areas
we most need it in the big decisions we
have to make our lives that's what I'd
love to see yeah me too I suppose a part
of that is people developing the
awareness of the value of their
attention so that they are perhaps
willing to pay for things that preserve
and that attention and treated as sacred
by design right exactly attention is a
scarce resource I mean it is a certainly
a a limited resource I know we only have
perhaps a handful of minutes left and
I'd love to ask you as someone who I
would I would imagine has read quite a
few books in your day and you mentioned
if you've mentioned a few you mentioned
metaphors we live by you mentioned
amusing ourselves to death are there any
particular books that you have gifted
often to other people or tend to
recommend most often or have recommended
a lot to other people did do any come to
mind it's a great question you know Neil
postman in general as a media thinker
about some of the topics we discussed
today is just excellent I mean he
foresaw so many of the problems and his
books amusing ourselves to death and
another one by him is called tecnópolis
which also is about how when culture
surrenders to technology and especially
the quantification of metrics and SAT
scores and time spent and GDP and these
kinds of things he covers in that book
highly recommend there's another book
called finite and infinite games do you
know this one yes I do buy cars and yes
James cars the religious studies
professor did you interview him your
mouth no I haven't I would certainly be
open to it
it's a fascinating fascinating book yeah
yeah and that's just a general
philosophy one about life and how to I
don't know
navigate in a more improvisational way
and ask like what what game am I really
playing in any interaction am i playing
for a finite game outcome to win the
game or am i playing to keep playing
which has a lot of overlaps with
improvisation and things like that
mm-hmm yeah that's a that's a fantastic
book people can get a very good taste of
it by going to Goodreads and looking at
highlighted portions for finite and
infinite and infinite games also highly
recommended by Stewart Brand and a lot
of other a lot of other really really
folks I respect a whole lot before and
I'm sorry because I said recommend one
more if you're into podcasts but someone
who I've learned a lot from in terms of
the civilization level dynamics around
you know finite games operating on her
infinite growth games operating on a
finite playing field and the kind of the
fundamental problems of capitalism I
recommend looking at Daniel 'shmock
canburger there's a future thinkers
podcasts episodes with him and his
thinking has been hugely informative to
my own so I recommend that for listeners
wonderful and I will figure out how to
spell that and that will go into the
show notes as well I this has been so
much fun just on I really appreciate you
taking the time these are important
topics these are these are timely but
only going to become more relevant and
more important
is there anything else you would like to
say anything else you would like to
point people to suggestions you'd like
to make anything at all that you'd like
to share as closing comments before we
wrap up um
well no first just thank you for having
me I've enjoyed it as well it's nice to
finally connect I think if had many
friends who've been trying to connect
this for a while yeah
and you know I think if you're
interested in how we reform the
attention economy and how technology's
been working I just recommend people
check out our work at the Center for
Humane technology you could find me on
Twitter at Patras Don Harris or the
senator free Maine technology website
humane techcom but uh you know this is
gonna take a village to make these
changes and I think it might seem really
hard but then what I would encourage
people to do is recognize that you know
our Paleolithic brains are not meant
like if you ask like is our Paleolithic
instincts are they designed to do well
to look at a massive problem like
climate change and just be like great
let's get to work or are they more
designed to look at a huge problem like
that and say oh my god I have no idea
what Zoo through me put my head in the
sand and it's definitely the latter and
I think that the thing that we have to
recognize is that when you see big
problems recognize the way that our
instincts would bias us to put our head
in the sands and ask instead well what
if there's no one else who's gonna solve
these problems but us
because my last big lesson that I'll
share with people because I've had a
crazy couple of years I've been in the
rooms with heads of state and you know
the the highest rooms possible
considering these problems there there
are no higher rooms and I used to think
in my life that there was this magic
river of adults somewhere that you know
we're actually thinking about all these
problems and they had it all figured out
and don't you worry Tim you know pad you
in the head yeah they've you know we've
got this one son you know we really have
this one figured out and I have my
lesson this year is no such room exists
around some of these big problems like
with climate change there there isn't
some master plan that everyone's working
on and with this one there isn't some
you know just group of people at
Facebook or like that's nice Tristana
but we're gonna fix this whole thing
like it
really is this emerging issue that I
think people need to get used to each of
us who can especially who have the
bandwidth to take responsibility for the
world that we live in and ask what can
we do because it was frightening and
terrifying to realize at first that
there wasn't a bunch of other adults you
know or at least not that many adults in
these rooms who knew the answers to
these questions and that suddenly I was
one of them and then the second part is
realizing Wow okay here we go
what what can we now do to navigate what
levers can we pull and I think if
everybody saw that they really were an
active agent in the system and not just
a passive participant they would we get
there a lot faster
so I really encourage people to do that
we are all John Connor
that's a great
well these is a very important message
and look forward to hopefully spending
some time together in person perhaps we
can rope in Eric and some other yeah
let's do that
thank you that I miss Eric and and
really appreciate you taking the time
again this is this has been a lot of fun
for me and very very enlightening very
insightful and I have a whole sheet of
notes that I've taken on things that I
want to follow up on I will link for
everyone listening to all of the the
social links the humane techcom and so
on in the show notes also all the books
we've mentioned everything else will be
linked at Tindall blog post podcast if
you just search for Tristan or Harris
although then Sam will pop up a couple
times as well so I have to parse that
and until next time yeah thank you so
much Don thank you so much for having me
again and to everybody out there thank
you so much for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday if that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favourite
new albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by LinkedIn jobs
hiring can be hard really hard and it
also be super super expensive and
painful if you get it wrong I certainly
have had that experience firsthand
multiple times and I'm not eager to
repeat it so I tried to do as much
vetting as possible on the front end and
today with more qualified candidates
than ever you need a solution be a
platform that helps you to find the
right people for your business LinkedIn
jobs does exactly that more than 600
million users visit LinkedIn to learn
make connections grows professionals and
more than ever discover new job
opportunities in fact overall LinkedIn
members add 15 new skills to their
profiles and apply to thirty five job
posts every two seconds its greatest at
LinkedIn does the legwork match you to
your most qualified candidates so that
you can focus on the hiring process
getting the person into your company who
will transform your business they make
sure your job posts gets in front of the
people with the right hard skills
and soft skills to meet your
requirements they've made it as easy as
possible so check it out to get $50 off
of your first job pose to go to
linkedin.com slash to him again that's
linkedin.com slash Tim to get $50 off of
your first job post terms and conditions
apply check it out
linkedin.com slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by me undies me undies
makes the softest undies known to man
that's what the copy says and they are
soft the really soft whether you like
crazy prints or opt for classic black
the undies gives you the freedom to
express yourself comfortably I wonder
what expressing yourself of course
within legal bounds means in this case
but I do like to express myself I'm
wearing some tie-dye the undies right
now as I record this in the room next to
me I've got some pizza and videogame
prints those are not on the same pair of
underwear with two separate ones and
I'll be packing for a trip and I have a
nice stack me and he's going with me why
because they're comfortable very very
comfortable the Indies has plenty of
options for those looking to up their
undie game you can join the monthly
membership you can do build a pack that
is building a 3 6 or 10 pack of your
favourite undies or socks and saving up
to 30% you can select a matching pair to
match with your better half or just pick
out one pair that strikes your fancy and
there's some pretty ridiculous ones and
that I specialize in personally the
undies are made with soft sustainable
fabric and available in sizes from extra
small to four XL fun new prints drop
every tuesday and members get access to
exclusive prints every month my undies
has a great offer for listeners of this
podcast for any first-time purchase you
get 15% off and free shipping they also
give you a 100% satisfaction guarantee
and I like to be satisfied with my
underwear to get your 15% off your first
order free shipping and a 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to me on
Descamps
Tim that's me undies calm / Tim
[Applause]